in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Richard
and Tiffany are with us hey guys how are
you great Dave how are you better than I
deserve
welcome where y'all from Phoenix Phoenix
Arizona welcome to Nashville thank you
good to have you and all the way over
here to do your debt-free scream yes I
love it and how much did you pay off a
hundred and sixteen thousand nine
hundred dollars way to go and how long
did that take thirty four months and
range of income during that time range
during that time probably a hundred to
about a hundred and seventy thousand
okay
very good that's a big bump yes what do
you guys do for a living I am multi
employed I am a graphic artist an
insurance salesman and I actually just
got my real estate license very cool and
what do you do to me I am a hairdresser
awesome so where did this bump and
income come from your hair dry the
hairdresser Wow very cool she actually
bought her own salon ah and it's working
yes all right very good we bought that
debt-free
well congratulations very cool so what
was the hundred and seventeen thousand
dollars in debt you paid off our
mortgage hey yes I'm looking at weird
people yeah I love it so what's the
house worth about 270 Wow very cool so
$270,000 paid for house not a debt in
the world you own your own business free
and clear and now your income shoots
through the roof of course yeah at the
perfect time you're gonna really
seriously build some wealth this is fun
yes it is congratulations so how does it
feel to have a paid-for house I don't
think it's really sunk in in yet
our trip out here is the culmination of
it yeah we've actually been working
there's more to the story we've actually
hosted about ten FPU class Wow thank you
so we started this back in 2006 actually
our total number is more like 205 Ryan
paid off but we've really gotten ghazal
intense in the last three years
Wow and just saw that you could say you
saw the light at the end the tunnel on
the house you can do it
yeah and you could reach over and smack
it very cool so how old are you guys
I'm gonna be 50 her birthday is today
she's 49 hey happy birthday yeah very
cool very cool
and you've a paid-for house yes just
like that
I want y'all been married going on 24
years very good have you ever been
debt-free while you were married yeah
first couple of years of our marriage we
didn't have a house so we really didn't
have any debt but then when we bought
the house we jumped right into
remodeling the whole thing yeah and
there and there we go yeah yeah Home
Depot card you name it yeah I can
Express card so what happened at the
beginning of this journey because it
sounds like you were like you said oh
six Oh about 10 years ago you started
this process which is about normal you
took you through three years to get out
of debt other than the house and then
seven years to pay off your house is
about right so what happened that caused
the switch to flip where you just
decided we're not gonna be normal we got
fed up
we were living paycheck to paycheck
actually living on our American Express
card which was awful mm-hmm and we
actually had another small business we
were hotdog vendors for a while okay we
went out to do a an event out in Yuma
Arizona and we put everything on the
American Express card and it was a flop
so on the way home we cut up the
American Express card and threw it out
the window
I know that car Oh God yeah so that the
hotdog flop was that as your WakeUpNow
and so how did you get connected to us
then I heard you on the radio
a little bit earlier but I think that's
when this this the switch flipped yes
okay and then you went through the class
obviously since you've led it in time
yes yeah very cool well congratulations
y'all thank you has seasoned FPU
coordinators that are standing here 50
years old and less with a paid-for house
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is budget being
together on the same page goals
absolutely written goals don't when we
put that we were gonna pay our house off
before I turn 50
down on paper we saw it happening yeah
instantly yes Tiffany what was the
hardest part of this for you guys you
know it wasn't hard he brought it to me
and I'm like let's do it um through the
journey I think we weren't good Sal
enough my husband likes to take
vacations and he's the fun guy I would
have been on rice and beans the whole
time okay all right so you hit the goal
yeah it wasn't difficult cool very cool
well congratulations are very proud of
you very proud for you thank you thanks
for leading the class because you got to
be inspiring coordinators with this
great story I mean here you sit with
that paid for house you're yes we're I
just want to thank you for all you do
for everybody else the financial piece I
got to go to your entree leadership back
in 2015 this song I will summit yeah it
was awesome yeah very cool well thank
you thanks for coming out guys all right
Richard a Tiffany 117,000 paid off
that's their house and everything baby
34 months it took to knock it out once
they got to that point a hundred
thousand one hundred and seventy
thousand income count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one we're
dead
that's a good one well done y'all well
done that's how it works right there man
that's awesome very very good hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you